hello in this video we'll talk about the
thyroid hormone secretion
so let's get a quick overview of the
thyroid hormone and then we would go to
the nitty gritty details
the thyroid hormone is produced by the
thyroid gland which is composed of two
lobes
which are located in the either side of
the trachea and they are connected by a
thin connective tissue flap known as
istimus
thyroid hormones that means the
triiodothyronine t3 or
tetrahydrothyroidin or thyroxine which
is known as t4 has a multitude of
functions for example thyroid hormones
regulate basal metabolic rate they can
regulate erythropoiesis they regulate
metabolism of carbohydrate fat and
proteins they are also involved in
maintenance of water and electrolyte
balance lastly thyroid hormone derived
thyroid gland derived thyrocalcitonin
also regulates blood calcium levels so
it plays variety of functions now in
this particular video we are not going
to delve into the details of
functionality of thyroid hormones but we
are going to look at the cellular
process by which thyroid hormone is
produced inside the thyroid follicles
so here is a cross-section of the
thyroid gland you can see inside there
are a lot of circular structures which
are known as thyroid follicles
so each of these thyroid follicle has a
lot of thyroid follicular cells which
are cuboidal cells and these thyroid
inside these uh thyroid follicle there
would be a dense substance which is
known as colloid inside the colloid
there are thyroglobulin which are
actually precursors of the thyroid
hormone
now let's look at this process in bit
more details everything starts from the
pituitary so from the pituitary the tsh
hormone would be actually secreted and
it would target the thyroid gland
and in the thyroid follicular cell there
are a lot of tsh receptors
this tsh receptor and tsh interaction
leads to a signaling cascade which
ultimately allows
thyroid
thyroglobulin to be processed into a
thyroid hormone but first the thyroid
hormone production requires iodine
so iodine has to get into the thyroid
hydrocolloid
by the help of specific transporters and
it is actually co-transported with
sodium
so this iodine is now moving into the
colloid and inside the colloid with the
help of the enzyme thyroperoxidase and
hydrox and
hydrogen peroxide the iodine would be
now converted to a molecular form or i2
form
now let's zoom into these thyroid
follicular cells to understand the
process better
so the thyroglobulin is actually
a chain of tyrosine molecules because
thyroid hormones are actually tyrosine
derivatives
so this chain is actually
secreted
via the cellular secretory
machinery
so it goes from er to the golgi and from
the golgi it takes the cellular
excretory root and then ultimately it is
released in the colloid
inside the colloid this particular
thyroglobulin would be further
processed
and one of the important procedure that
it would undergo is called iodination so
let's look at that procedure in bit more
details
there could be iodination in one
particular location it would lead to
production of mono iodo tyrosine so it's
basically iodination of the tyrosine
moieties here then there could be
dihydrotyrosine and all of these
elements can be
linked to each other in permutation and
combination for example
so dihydrotyrosine and monoi to tyrosine
that means mit and dit can combine with
each other to form t3
whereas two uh diido tyrosine can
actually form t4
now all of these things are still linked
in a chain
and in this immature thyroglobulin
format now this immature thyroglobulin
would actually be taken inside
the
thyroid follicular cells
now the biggest
fact about thyroid hormones are the
thyroid gland is usually storing these
kind of hormones in an uh precursor
format for a very long time that's
pretty unusual about thyroid thyroid
gland and thyroid hormones
now let's say there is a need of
secretion of thyroid hormone so these
thyroglobulin which are kind of
iodinated
this would be again
uh uptaken by the thyroid follicular
cell by the process of pinocytosis
so there are there would be pinocytic
vesicles taking inside this thyroid
building
once the thyroglobulin is inside it
would be further processed
by specific mechanisms such as the
lysosomal proteases would cleave and
chop off all these
tyrosine residue from this chain and
free them to be secreted into the
bloodstream
now inside the bloodstream these
hormones are not alone
very small fraction of them are freely
uh moving around but the large fraction
is actually complex with carriers such
as uh mammalian specific tbg albumin or
trans hydrogen and they are complex with
this carrier and thereby they are
delivered to the location where they are
required so i hope this particular video
describes the process of thyroid hormone
production and secretion of the thyroid
hormone i hope this is interesting other
videos would describe how thyroid
hormone actually works at a molecular
level uh click on the video in the i
button there are also going to be videos
which talk about the thyroid hormone
function and overall diseases associated
with uh thyroid hormones so stay tuned
for more by the way all the notes
associated with these topics are
available in my facebook page the link
is provided in the description so check
it out don't forget to like share and
subscribe you can support my channel in
the patreon if you are an indian viewer
you can support me by uh via him upi app
and as usual i'm also present in academy
which is india's biggest learning
platform if you wish to connect to me in
social media feel free to connect and
present in all the social media all the
links are provided in the description
though thank you